Now, we're moving into
the world of native apps.
And this is a world that's flourishing.
You might notice some similarities
between what we spoke about for the web,
but there are also some specific
monetization methods for native apps.
>> At first, you need to think, what
would be the best model for your app?
It's likely to change, but that's fine.
You need to be agile and
listen to your customers.
Let's look at some of
the most popular options.
>> First, you can monetize premium apps.
That's selling your app for
a fixed price.
In a lot of cases, this might not
provide you with enough revenue, so
you can also optionally include ads or
use in-app billing to sell
additional features or content.
Now this model works great for
certain categories, like games for kids.
In this example, parents can
pay a full price up front, and
a model with like ads or in-app
purchases may not work as well since
the kid would have to
make those purchases.
However, this model may also limit your
app's monetization potential
in developing markets.
You may be able to achieve greater
revenue using the freemium subscription
or advertising model.
>> And monetizing freemium apps.
Users are more likely
to download a free app.
Later, you could use several
options to monetize.
First, use in app payments
to unlock more features.
For example, games like Angry Birds,
Clash of Clans and
many others, and productivity apps,
Evernote, Springnote,
all are using this to
provide a free tier.
Second, subscriptions for
recurring services.
It might be used progressively or
expire after a period of time, such as
a game booster or a news subscription.
Many examples like Pandora,
Financial Times, Strava,
Dropbox and many more are using it.
Another option is just to
leave the app free, and
use it as a marketing or
as an enhancement to another product.
>> E-commerce is another monetization
option
>> In this model, you can sell physical
goods, like tomatoes, clothing,
electronics, what have you.
And you can also sell other services.
Think about Etsy and
Amazon as good examples of e-commerce.
>> The question is, which model
gets the best results for your app?
Most app services are made
to help you figure out
what combination works best both for
your audience and your bottom line.
You should remember that you
will need a lot of traffic
in order to make this model work for
you.